hey guys this is Vadim with max tech in
this right here is our 2019 Mac Pro we
just unbox it it was probably the best
unboxing experience ever the boxes were
extremely heavy the design is incredibly
solid and amazing so in this video we're
gonna be testing the thermal performance
the fan noise and a bunch of benchmarks
and believe it or not it's turned on
right now and I literally cannot hear it
this configuration of the Mac Pro is
packing the 12 core Zeon 48 gigabytes of
6 channel RAM and the powerful Vega 2
graphics card with 32 gigabytes of vram
the reason we got this specific
configuration is because we believe it's
a very good middle-of-the-road
configuration for a lot of professionals
now the only thing we would change about
the setup is the RAM and we actually did
we ordered 192 gigs of memory for under
$700 compared to paying Apple three
thousand dollars for the upgrade so in
tomorrow's video make sure to subscribe
because in that video we're gonna show
you how easy it is to change the RAM
yourself it's actually the easiest out
of any Mac machine now we did order the
optional afterburner card because if
want to test out if it's worth the extra
two thousand dollars for those who work
in that format but we think that most
people don't need it let's start with
the fans now what's surprising me the
most about the Mac Pro is that this
whole time I haven't been able to hear
it at all so what we're gonna do right
here is we're gonna go into T G fan Pro
and check out the fan speeds alright so
this is very interesting I got four fans
right here the first one looks to be the
power supply fan and it looks like it's
at the minimum speed around 500 rpms and
one of the three case fans is completely
at the minimum and these two are just
slightly above at around 540 to 593 rpm
and it's interesting that the maximum
for these three is 2500 now the 16 inch
MacBook Pro surprised us because it was
actually a little bit lower than before
it was at 5700 compared to 6000 and this
only goes up to 2500 so what I'm gonna
do now is hit this max button and see
how loud these fans can get if it
absolutely has to
all right so they're maxed out right now
Oh
can you guys hear that whoa Wow look at
that all red right here maxed out Wow
all right so I could definitely hear
that right now so if it needs to we can
definitely get pretty loud with a lot of
airflow I can actually feel it right now
like you can you could dry your hair
with this there's a lot of airflow back
here but we're gonna be testing our
benchmarks to see if we can overload the
system with as much as we can to see if
it can actually get anywhere near this
loud so right here I have cinnamon chart
20 open and right next to it until
powered gadget so we can look at the
frequencies the power draw the temps but
first a huge thinking micro Center for
making our Mac Pro content possible
micro Center has 25 stores nationwide
with an impressive variety of
electronics from gaming VR computer
parts like processors graphics and
everything else needed to build or
upgrade a PC or Mac Micro Center has
been an Apple authorized dealer since
1980 they have a dedicated Apple
Department and with highly trained Apple
sales associates aside from the iPhone
Micro Center carries the full line of
Apple products and they have the largest
selection of third-party products made
for Mac and iPad come into a local Micro
Center today and talk to one of their
Apple experts to order the specific Mac
Pro configuration that best suits your
needs check the link in the video
description to find a location near you
or browse all of micro centers Apple
products back to the Mac let's go ahead
and run Cinebench r20 so it looks like
the frequencies are not going below 3.7
gigahertz which is really good because
the base is 3 point 3 and the temps
stayed below 55 degrees the whole time
that's very interesting we just hit 50
432 points Cinebench are 20 this is
actually higher than we expected because
it's 50% faster than our iMac pro which
is packed in the 8 core Xeon processor
another interesting thing we notice is
that the fans did not kick up at all and
it did not go past 55 degrees Celsius
during that whole test and now we're
sending a 32 degrees Celsius idle which
is actually quite good alright so we
just started the fifth consecutive run
of cinnamon jar 20 the
frequencies are staying the same the
temps are under 69 degrees right now and
look at the fans right here two fans are
still completely at the minimum and
these are still just slightly over
they're not up at all I can't hear this
thing at all we're on their fifth run
and we're maxing out the CPU 100% as you
guys can see right there this is weird
so even though these fans can get pretty
loud if you max them out as you guys
just saw five or six consecutive runs
100% CPU usage the fans are barely above
the minimum I can't even hear it right
now so if you like silent machines this
is literally the one to get now getting
into benchmarks we're gonna start off
with Geekbench fives cpu test and right
here we have a multi-core score of
twelve thousand five hundred and
eighteen
now that's around fifty five percent
faster than our iMac Pro as you guys
know we can already get really high core
counts like on the iMac Pro up to 18
cores but what we can't get is really
high graphics performance so right now
we're running geek bench fives metal
tests so the results are in and we got a
geek bench five metal score of eighty
six thousand seven hundred and sixteen
that's about eighty five percent faster
than our iMac Pro and as you guys can
see if you look at geek bench fives
metal benchmarks charts online it
completely blows away everything that's
here the highest score here is sixty six
thousand nine hundred and right here we
have eighty six thousand seven hundred
and sixteen that's just with one pro two
GPU and here you can actually get four
of those in this Mac Pro now let's also
test the graphics performance and the
Blackmagic raw speed test and this is
gonna be mainly for video editing of raw
footage the right here for the 8k metal
we're getting a hundred and fourteen fps
so what this shows us is that this can
handle four streams of 8k Blackmagic raw
and multicam and looking over here at 4k
that's around twenty streams of 4k
Blackmagic rock at the same time with
the single Vega - not even the dual but
the single now if you want to see a lot
more detail about video editing go down
in the video description
click on Max's video that's fully
dedicated on video editing with the Mac
Pro so that makes me very curious about
gaming performance now I know nobody's
gonna buy this to play games don't do
that but let's say after your work is
done maybe you want to launch some games
just a little bit on the side so let's
go ahead and run Unigine heavens
benchmark on the extreme preset and see
how well the vega 2 performs for gaming
it's been running for quite some time
and i still can't hear the Mac Pro and
looking over here at the temperature
it's at 68 degrees Celsius which is
really good usually GPUs try to stay
below 85 now looking at the fan speeds
below you can see that there's still
just barely over the minimum and I still
can't hear the Mac Pro 112 point 6 fps
that's about 50% more FPS than our iMac
Pro so if you guys are gonna choose to
play games on the Mac Pro it's gonna
absolutely kill and it's going to be
completely silent while doing it so
since this is doing so well we're
actually going to combine the Mac Pro
with Apple's new 6k Pro XD our display
playing at 6k resolution to see how well
it performs in gaming so if you're not
already subscribed do that right now
because that video is coming very soon
now for all of you 3d animators and
renderers we're gonna run blenders
graphics benchmark we're about halfway
through this test and if you look over
here in ISTEP menus we can see the VRAM
usage of this graphics card and we can
see that right here we're actually
sitting below 50% VRAM usage so that's
below 16 gigabytes of vram during
blender rendering all right so blender
benchmark just finished and it looks
like we got a score of 16 minutes and 4
seconds for reference our imac pro
finished this test in one hour in 55
minutes which is an absolutely massive
difference that's over seven times
faster with this Mac Pro compared to our
iMac Pro and we're not exactly sure why
this happened what we noticed this trend
with all of the last gen Vega graphics
the Vega 20 the 48 the 56 the 64
compared to the new Navi 7 nanometre
graphics that's in the Mac
that's in the 16 inch MacBook Pro these
graphics are finishing 3d rendering
benchmarks like blender a lot quicker
than the older gen based on what we've
seen from this test if you're gonna go
with a third-party graphics card in your
mac pro we highly recommend that you go
with the Radeon 5700 XT or the Radeon 7
because both of those feature AMD's Navi
7 nanometre graphics but we'd proudly
recommend the Radeon 7 because it does
have 16 gigabytes of the superfast
HBM 2 graphics memory and now for our
final extreme stress test we're gonna
run Cinebench our 20 back-to-back while
Unigine heaven benchmark is running so
that's gonna max out the CPU and the GPU
at the same time and we're gonna look at
those fan speeds we've been doing
consecutive runs of our 20 we're
actually on the fourth run Unigine
Heaven is finishing up and looking right
here the fans didn't change at all
they're still at the same slightly over
minimum fan speed which is really odd I
still can't hear it haven't heard it at
all this whole time this is shocking
even with the CPU and GPU at a hundred
percent maxed out it's still dead silent
which is insane because this this test
right here would get the Mac Pro and the
iMac pro loud and this is still dead
silent so there you guys have it let us
know down in the comments section below
what you guys thought about these
benchmarks and thermal performance tests
we're also going to be doing a lot more
videos on the Mac Pro in the 6k pro xcr
display coming very soon so if you're
not already subscribed make sure to
click that circle above right now to do
so it's have the like button below and
we'll see you in those videos very soon
you
[Music]